people who have been shocked by the
system we're now trying ways to unfuck
themselves there's a lot of things that
people think is like 15 years away that
you'll see in 6-8 months we're in a
world of exponentially advancing
technology and exponentially advancing
technology cannot survive the
bottlenecks of bureaucracy here in this
downtown Oakland Community Center over a
hundred citizen scientists gathered for
the bio hack the planet conference many
of them have set up labs and garages and
don't have any formal degree whatsoever
the stigma of smart people and science
is invented science works no matter who
you are
instead of breaking into and
manipulating computer systems like
typical hackers they're focused on
hacking living organisms with the hopes
of curing illness and in some cases
obtaining superhuman powers their shared
mission is to put this technology into
the hands of as many people as possible
people should be able to use all the
technologies that science develops right
it shouldn't be just patented and given
to companies or exclusively given to
certain people there's a lot of
innovation that people have no idea
about and if you're not way up in the
middle of it there's a lot of things
that people think is like 15 years away
that you'll see in six eight months and
I mean it's these do-it-yourself
biologists say the democratization of
science has given them the freedom to
work on projects that are often ignored
by larger institutions they're using
gene editing technologies like CRISPR to
create personalized treatments for those
suffering from rare diseases or cancer
experimenting with magnetic and
vibrating implants to alter the sensory
experience reverse engineering
pharmaceuticals like epi pens so people
can make their own medicine at home and
even creating glow-in-the-dark beer I
think this is the most exciting time
thus far in the history of the world to
be alive personalized medicine is going
to change everything it's gonna rock the
world because you can't do a clinical
trial on one person but medicine is
starting to progress to the point where
I can sequence your genome
I can sequence your cancers you know I
can find the difference I can develop an
amino therapy so that I can get your
body to respond to your cancer
specifically not anybody else's cancer
but I also can't test that on anybody
but you that's gonna be crazy and that's
gonna be awesome
earlier this year the Food and Drug
Administration began placing
restrictions on non-human genetic
modifications and declared that
genetically edited animals must be
classified as drugs this would give the
agency broad authority over a number of
do-it-yourself genetics tests and would
require experiments involving animals to
go through the same vetting process as a
new drug I guess they couldn't call them
cosmetics they couldn't call them foods
they're like dogs or drugs David ishi
a canine breeder from Mississippi who is
working on editing out genetic diseases
and dogs says the restrictions will mean
only large companies can research
genetic cures for animals everybody's
worried about what somebody could do
with this technology and nobody seems to
care about the damage that not doing it
will cause like these animals that are
dying or dying anyway like they're gonna
die every day until we do something
about it
regulation could undermine biohacking
breakthroughs for humans as well and
people are so afraid of how will this be
used in the wrong way you know what I'm
afraid of I'm afraid that all these
people dying of [ __ ] cancer and all
these people who are dying of hunger
aren't gonna get cured aren't gonna get
fed because we're not allowing people to
have access to this technology that's
governed by a regulatory framework
cobbled together in the mid 80s out of
statutes that are now 70 and 80 years
old that existed before we knew DNA was
important the regulations don't fit the
reality and are not set up to try to
distinguish between good uses and bad
uses I'm a huge fan of deregulation
because I believe in the inherent
goodness of like capitalism and
everything like stuff doesn't progress
unless people do useful things with it
right and people are naturally inclined
to stop bad things that happen with it
we will be able to design life in ways
that the 19th century taught us had to
design buildings life is going to become
something that we may
can remake and edit and re-edit if we
are genuine proponents of freedom then
people should have the Liberty to use
their bodies in whatever way they see
fit and to undertake inquiry and think
and explore however they see fit
[Music]